better than a thousand hollow words is
one word Buddha I'm going to share a
secret with you a secret so powerful
that once you discover it every decision
you make in your life and business will
become easier doors will start to open
where before you struggle to make any
progress you'll finally feel like you're
living your life with a purpose instead
of fighting the world around you
great leaders have used this secret to
build powerful companies spark important
movements and create meaningful change
and now you can too here's the secret
there is one word that defines who you
are there is one word that connects all
the things in your life that make you
come alive think about the friends you
have the music you listen to the books
you read the movies you watch the
companies you've worked for the
businesses you started think about
everything in your life right now that
you enjoy they're all connected until
you figure out what that connection is
you'll never live up to your potential
what's your favorite song and what does
it have to do with who your best friend
their favorite book is the answer is
everything and that can be boiled down
to one simple powerful word great people
can be described in one word Martin
Luther King jr. equality Oprah Winfrey
Hart Steve Jobs impact how about you
if you want to break free from the
chains of mediocrity and really make an
impact then it starts with finding your
one word you have to stand for something
powerful and important